let me ask a slightly philosophical fun
question gotta ask i know you're focused
on getting to mars but once we're there
on mars what do you what form of
government economic system
political system do you think would work
best for an early civilization of humans
is
i mean
the the interesting reason to talk about
this stuff it also make helps people
dream about the future i know you're
really focused about the short-term
engineering dream but it's like i don't
know there's something about imagining
an actual civilization on mars that
gives people
so it really gives people hope well it
would be a new frontier and an
opportunity to rethink the whole nature
of government just as was done in the
creation of the united states
so
i mean i would suggest
having a
direct democracy like people vote
directly on things as opposed to
representative democracy so
uh representative democracy i think is
too
uh subject to a special interest and
you know a coercion of the politicians
and that kind of thing
um
so i i'd recommend
uh
that that there's just
um direct democracy people vote on laws
the population votes on laws themselves
and then the laws must be short enough
that people can understand them
yeah and then like keeping a
well-informed populist like really being
transparent about all the information
about what they're voting for absolute
transparency yeah and not make it as
annoying as those cookies we have to
accept
cookies like always like
you know there's like always like a
slight amount of trepidation when you
click accept cookies like i feel as
though there's like perhaps like a like
a very tiny chance that'll open a portal
to hell or something like that
that's exactly how i feel why why do
they why do they keep wanting to accept
that what do they want with this cookie
like somebody got upset with accepting
cookies or something somewhere
who cares like
it's so annoying to get keep accepting
all these cookies to me this is just
a great accent yes you can have my damn
cookie i don't care whatever
you heard from me on first he accepts
all your damn cookies yeah
and start asking me
annoying
yeah it's uh it's
one example of um
implementation of a good idea done
really horribly yeah it's somebody was
like there's some good intentions of
like
privacy or whatever but now everyone's
just has to take accept cookies and it's
not you know you have billions of people
who have to keep clicking except cookie
it's super annoying
then we just accept the damn cookie it's
fine
there is like um
i think a fundamental problem that we're
because we've not really had a
a major
uh like a world war or something like
that in a while and obviously we would
like to not have world wars um
the there's not been a cleansing
function for rules and regulations
so wars did have uh you know some sort
of lining in that there would be a
reset on rules and regulations uh after
a war so world wars one and two there
were huge resets on rules and
regulations um
now as
if if the society society does not have
a war
and there's no cleansing function or
garbage collection for rules and
regulations then rules and regulations
will accumulate every year because
they're immortal there's no actual
humans die but the laws don't
uh so
the we need a garbage collection
function for rules and regulations they
should not just
be immortal um because some of the rules
and regulations that are put in place
will be counterproductive
done with good intentions but
counterproductive sometimes not done
with good intentions
so
if you just if rules and regulations
just accumulate every year
and you get more and more of them then
eventually you won't be able to do
anything you're just like gulliver with
you know tied down by thousands of
little strings
and we we see that in
um you know
us and
like basically all economies that uh
have been around for for a while uh and
and regulators and legislators create
new rules and regulations every year but
they don't put effort into removing them
and i think that's very important that
we put effort into removing rules and
regulations
um
but it gets tough because you get
special interests that then are
dependent on like they they have a you
know a uh
vested interest in that whatever rule
and regulation and that they then they
fight
to not get it removed
um
yeah so it i mean i guess the problem
with the constitution is it's it's kind
of like c
versus java because it doesn't have any
garbage collection built in i think
there should be i like when you first
said the the the metaphor of garbage
collection from coding standpoint from
the county standpoint yeah yeah i it
would be interesting interesting if the
laws themselves kind of had a built-in
thing where they kind of die after a
while unless somebody explicitly
publicly defends them yeah so that
that's sort of it's not like somebody
has to kill them they kind of die
themselves
they disappear yeah
um
not to defend java or anything but you
know the c plus plus you know you could
also have a great garbage collection in
python and so on yeah so yeah
something's good something needs to
happen
or or just the the civilization's
arteries arteries just harden over time
and and uh you can just get less and
less done because there's just a rule
against everything
um
so
yeah i think like i don't know for mars
order i'd say or important here
obviously for earth as well like i think
there should be an active process for
removing
rules and regulations and questioning
their existence
just um like if we've got a function for
creating rules and regulations because
rules and regulations you can also think
of as like they're like software or
lines of code for operating
uh
civilization that's the rules and
regulations um
so it's like we shouldn't have rules and
regulations but you have code
accumulation but no code removal
um and so it just gets
to be become basically archaic bloatware
after a while
um and and it's just it makes it hard
for things to progress
so
i don't know maybe mars you'd have like
an uh
you know any given law must have a
sunset you know and and and uh and
require active
voting to keep
restoring to keep it up there you know
um i actually also say like
and these just i don't know
recommendations or thoughts and
ultimately it will be up to the people
on mars to decide but
i think
it should be easier to
remove a law than to add one because of
the just to overcome the inertia of laws
so
maybe it's like uh
for argument's sake you need like say 60
percent vote to have a law take effect
but only a forty percent vote to remove
it
you